[Musique]
inutile de vous présenter le docteur
jimmy mohamed chronique assure balances
ton pâté sûreté pmp à plusieurs reprises
essentiellement intervenu au moment de
la pandémie coville pour nous distiller
ses précieux conseils et ferait confiné
de façon totale le pays un peu comme en
mars pour sortir le plus rapidement la
crise aujourd'hui il est de retour pour
nous parler santé et bien-être avec la
sortie de son livre zéro contrainte
surtout ne changez rien me mohamed nous
dit comment faire pour rester en bonne
santé il faut quand même reconnaître
quand il ya des choses qui vont bien et
annoncé quelques bonnes nouvelles manger
mieux pratiquer une activité sportive à
arrêter de fumer ou de boire ce soir
jimmy mohamed vous reçoit dans le
cabinet des pmp
merci d'être là je suis très heureux de
voir c'est comme je t'ai mois ci avec
ton mot dans son livre m'a fait
extrêmement plaisir enfin voila tu sais
que tu seras toujours mon ami aussi tu
pourra toujours compter sur moi montigny
me suis tu n'as pas besoin de moi timmy
médecin et auteur et c'est vrai que là
il ya 48 astuce très très intéressante
on va revenir sur pas mal d'entre elles
et cirés que vous avez décidé d'aider
les français en bonne santé on a vécu
une période assez particulière plein
d'injonction de contraintes et on se
rend compte qu'on n'est pas tous égaux
face à la maladie en revanche on a des
conseils du quotidien qu'on peut tous
appliqués pour mettre toutes les chances
de notre côté et éviter d'être malade
souvent on va prendre des médicaments
pour se soigner or on oublie que le
meilleur des traitements c'est la
prévention donc l'idée c'est dans ce
livre 48 astuces lessard sans contrainte
toutes validées scientifiquement qui
nous permette de vivre en plus bonne
santé et plus longtemps pas exactement
voilà non plus bonne santé et plus
longtemps regardé daniel séverac à 112
ans les
réunions de rentrée on en est là suivi
les conseils de dieu alors la méthode 4
7 8% dormir ça c'est quoi parce qu'il ya
beaucoup de gens qui dorment mal une
technique pour s'endormir en 60 secondes
exactement alors c'est vrai qu'on oublie
qu'on vit une période assez particulière
où toute la journée on va être exposé à
des informations un peu stressante on va
être sur les réseaux sociaux et tout
d'un coup lorsqu'on se couche on
voudrait pouvoir dormir en un claquement
de doigts en or on a besoin d'une
période de transition on sait les
enfants ils ont besoin d'un rituel on le
raconte une petite histoire qu'on leur
brosse les dents qu'on fasse toujours la
même chose et nous aussi on a besoin
d'un rituel d'une période de transition
4 7 8 c'est une technique d'un chercheur
américain extrêmement efficace qui coûte
rien c'est pas des médicaments qui
permet de s'endormir en 60 secondes le
principe est simple c'est de la
cohérence cardiaque en contrôlant notre
respiration on va contrôler la fréquence
cardiaque c'est à dire la vitesse à
l'accueil laquelle le coeur bat pour
faire très simple vous allez prendre une
inspiration durant quatre secondes
vous bloquer pendant sept secondes ne le
fait pas vraiment vous avez vous
nous expliquer sur huit secondes accord
donc fait 4 7 8 a fait quatre voies la
tête et on espère lui seconde vitesse à
3 4 fois sans vous en rendre compte vous
aller chasser les pensées négatives
quant à notre coeur va se ralentir et
vous allez vous endormir plus facilement
à mal l'idée de comprendre c'est que le
sommeil c'est peut-être le meilleur des
médicaments qu'on puisse savoir qui
s'endort difficilement ainsi une quête
tout le monde ah ouais à tout le monde
prétend pas
[Rires]
dans le rouge
sa femme est partie il ya des enfants
qui naissent
puis
merci à demain non mais c'est fou non
mais vous vous les bonnes questions non
mes chiens j'ai un bep j'ai un point
commun et cristiano ronaldo en fait
qu'au lieu de faire des nuits complètes
de sommeil de cette heure je fais une
succession de micro sieste la journée de
1h ou trois heures à ce que celles
recommandées ou pas alors que votre état
non micro-sieste trois armées coincé
dans la journée dont il fait voir de
façon idéale devrait durer moins de 20
minutes en dehors de 20 minutes on va
tomber dans une semaine dans une phase
du sommeil beaucoup plus profond né le
réveil va être difficile si on veut
faire quelque chose pour être en forme
cette sphère sur l'appel 1 à puccino le
principe est simple c'est la contraction
entre technip faire une sieste et
prendre un cappuccino donc l'idée si un
moment vous avez une journée vous devez
absolument productif vous n'avez pas
beaucoup dormi vous prenez un café vous
allez faire une sieste au bout de 20
minutes la caféine va faire effet vous
allez vous réveiller de votre sieste la
commande avec ce double bénéfice à la
fin de la caféine
alors ils sont neuf vous nous fait une
petite frayeur avec ce titre qui prête à
confusion ne soyez pas un frotteur dans
ce chapitre vous fait tant rire en fait
référence au frottement des yeux
apparemment il pourrait nous rendre
aveugle exactement alors en fait c'est
un geste qu'on a tous fait ou qu'on fait
régulièrement qu'on peut faire et à la
période d'essai des énergies qui va
arriver mais est donc regarder sur ces
images qui se passe lorsque vous frotter
les yeux vous avez une déformation du
globe oculaire c'est des patients qu'on
a mis dans des irm et on se rend compte
que lorsqu'il se frotte les yeux eh bien
ils vont dé former une couche de l'oeil
qu'on appelle la cornée en faisant ça
sur le long terme sa bouche est une
pathologie qu'on appelle le kératocône
c'est ce que vous avez une autre image
aujourd'hui le kératocône en dire un
truc dans un dessin animé en direct
ouais d'accord c'est une déformation de
la cornée qui est irréversible qui
aboutit à une baisse de la vision qu'on
ne pourra pas traiter avec des lunettes
le traitement utile c'est la greffe de
cornée et donc il faudrait éviter de se
frotter les yeux pour limiter certaine
myopie
midi super bien mais quand ça démange de
ouf et bien justement l'idée c'est de
traiter les allergies saisonnières
mais si c'est pas énergie ce que c'est
un tic c'est une habitude il peut avoir
lorsqu'on est fatigué je vous rappelle
que lorsque vous êtes fatigué vous allez
- cligner des yeux c'est ce que lorsque
vous clignez - des yeux vous sécréter
moins de liquide de niveau de l'oeil et
donc forcément c'est le il va être sec
vous allez avoir ce mouvement pour avoir
traîné des sécrétions niveau de l'oeil
non par hu man la cia de la spéciale en
boarder
il déteste ça les 200 casques avait
détesté quand on parle de ce mois sacré
c'est dégoûtant cette action qui ont un
jour quand j'étais jeune je voulais
mettre des lentilles a été démentie
bon allez
on y croit
je ne sais pas ça ça m'angoisse et après
j'avais peur de l'imec comme ça bon moi
je me suis dit de façon si je peux pécho
j'aimais quand même voilà ce qu
important mais c'est vrai que c'est moi
salle un génie je peux pas mettre un
truc dans l'oeil mais n'ont pas
franchement c'est tout tu n as qu lire
quand même du collyre je vais mettre du
collyre j'ai fait une affection de
l'oeil qu'il va mettre du collyre
d'eaubonne il n'y avait qu'une piqûre
pour faire une anesthésie de l'oeil je
suis dit non je dois pas me mettre une
piqûre dans les yeux j'ai pleuré comme
un gosse de 6 ans m'a fait la piqûre
j'étais bien je me suis endormi
et j'ai peur du double
dames dire si c'est pas vrai dans la
peau mate c'est vrai c'est vrai du mythe
de la pommade il fallait que je mette de
la pommade dans le noir merci à ces
horribles leur invention fou total merci
le cannabis l'ennemi des tistics alors
ça c'est peu connu c'est vrai quand on
parle du cannabis on a l'impression que
c'est une drogue douce et tout le monde
me dira vous inquiétez pas le cannabis
est rien on le sait le cannabis à des
effets secondaires sur la motivation sur
le risque de maladies psychiatriques si
vous avez une prédisposition vous avez
un risque augmenté de schizophrénie mais
ce qu'on sait moins c'est que permet de
fumer jamais on a des récepteurs au
cannabis dans le cerveau un peu partout
dans le corps mais aussi dans les
testicules et la consommation de
cannabis va diminuer la quantité de
testicules les testicules vont être
moins mobiles dans testicules vous avez
j'ai mes testicules qui se
donne testicules moins mobile et ça il
va la voir en moins grande quantité et
puis ils vont avoir une forme un peu
particulière avec deux ou trois têtes et
on sait les mutants mis les personnes
qui vont faciliter 10% sont des fumeurs
de cannabis donc pour votre reproduction
mais il faut éviter de consommer du
cannabis et pour les femmes alors il ya
aussi un effet mais c'est parce que
n'oubliez pas que le cannabis est
souvent consommée avec du tabac or on
sait que le tabac alter aussi la
fertilité donc finalement tabakh l amith
singhal même combat ah ouais oui hélas
le cbd s'appelle influence sur le cpdc
que c'est un des composés du cannabis
dans le cannabis vous avez le cbd
notamment et le thc qui va être
responsable des effets psychogène le cbd
n'a pas d'effets secondaires pas
d'accoutumance et pas de risque pour la
santé alors vous dites aussi que porter
des slips ou des boxers pour prendre
soin de vos testicules oui alors ça
paraît tout bête alors n'oubliez pas que
les testicules ils sont à l'extérieur du
corps humain puisque les spermatozoïdes
doivent être à une température un peu
plus fraîche que le reste du corps sinon
c'est moi je l'aimé toujours
[Applaudissements]
la fierté
est encore mettez tous les matins du
poulet
je devais de les mettre dans le
compartiment du côté du
chien border oui mais on sait que le
disparu il n'aime pas la chaleur donc à
certains métiers aussi les pizzaïolos
les cuisiniers les boulangers qui vont
avoir un peu moins de spermatozoïdes que
les wackies honda motor
je ne portais pas de ce type ou de boxer
les testicules vont penderie yann
chirurgie qui en pleine expansion le
lifting du scrotum du fait d'avoir des
testicules qui pendent vers le bas
jusqu'au niveau de
l'aéro 5000 euros pendant l'été les
testicules ou comment ça se passe et un
mec dernier qui vous rend accessible au
bloc opératoire moi j'ai vu un mec les
alternant montées même si les bulls ne
faut pas se balader sur la leyre j'avais
voulu faire du loroux dans mes cinq
mille euros là le lifting du scrotum tv
y avait des mecs qui reçoit
opération
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
même si l'heure est proche pour
[Musique]
regarder
[Rires]
j'ai entendu dire qu'il existait des
slips castres en ont contre les
bouboules parce qu'elle n'aime pas la
chaleur et quand ça remonte trop haut ça
tue les spermatozoïdes c'est ça j'ai
entendu parler un moyen de contraception
qui n'est pas encore validé mais
effectivement c'est une nouvelle tornade
vaches on se dit pourquoi est-ce qu'on
laisserait systématiquement le poil la
contraception aux femmes on va leur
donner des hormones on va leur poser un
stérilet on a accepté pendant de
nombreuses années des effets secondaires
et donc certains hommes se disent
pourquoi nous on n'essayait pas
d'assumer aussi la contraception et
certains vont porter quelque chose qui
va remonter les testicules allons donc
être un peu plus à l'intérieur du corps
humain à la température va augmenter
j'ai dit que c'est un match où il ne
fait pas la température et donc c'est un
moyen de contraception qui n'est pas
encore validé mais on peut imaginer
après qu'il répare et que même mes
poèmes à capri les écrits
mais moi j'ai un copain sans même
s'excuser il mettait des glaçons dans
son slip maintenant il faut regarder ses
testicules offrait sa délégation sa
chambre il avait de quoi surfer
des vagues nous
on a d'autres infos dans un instant pas
cheap attiches ah ouais on va en parler
les risques de la chicha booster son
immunité grâce au sourire on va en
parler également vous allez voir on va
parler encore voilà que tout dit et le
bonheur un jeu d'enfant vous allez voir
comment être heureux comme un vrai
bonheur grâce à 10 me mohamed 48 conseil
on adore ce livre on en parle encore
dans un instant